malgré les mensonges la haine et la
rancoeur des êtres qui nous ont
abandonnés l'amour sera toujours plus
fort que toi c'est un poète c'est une
parole de chance car hugo qui a dit ça
philosophe je bois un peu je fais ce que
je veux décidemment ce
nom evangeline ans et quelques rares
titres est connue mariage est très connu
mais n'en connaissez je sais comme elle
savait aimé cref comme et rappelle ta
copine tu as peu arielle dombasle m'a
pas du tout à mon pardon laeticia
hallyday
ah oui personne là bas c'est bravo à toi
mais oui à sa fille joy sur instagram
regarder ce qu'elle a marqué ce week-end
donc la fim et de johnny un john yalley
publie une photo d'elle avec son papa il
a écrit mon père et moi sommes tellement
pareil je t'aime sommes tellement pareil
georges suis plus pareil que lui quel
est ce que je vous rappelle qu'ils sont
en froid oui janvier laetitia alors elle
lui écrit elle pour lui à lui répondre
tu lui ressemble tellement mon bébé
phoque je prends une poignée asthme tu
leur semble tellement mon bébé et tu
pourras t'en toi ses plus belles valeurs
et son amour inconditionnel
tu es également alcoolique dans ses
passes
il ne cessera jamais de te guider or cet
amour que personne ne pourra jamais te
voler mon ange malgré les mensonges la
haine et la rancoeur des êtres qui nous
ont abandonnés l'amour sera toujours
plus fort que tout moi j'ai un truc à
dire là-dessus mais je vais vous laisser
faire comment passer des messages
lorient un oui parce qu'il faut il faut
rappeler qu'il ya eu un accord sur
l'héritage sans le sait depuis l'époque
où la présente depuis laëtitia ne manque
jamais l'occasion de rappeler à rio
grosso modo que laura et david ont tiré
un trait sur leurs deux soeurs leurs
deux demi soeurs et dès qu'elle donne
une interview dès qu'elle peut faire un
post instagram où elle rappelle le fait
qu'ils ont pris leurs distances elle le
fait là ses scanners et c'est pour ça
qu'on ne s'entend pas avec
que l'on m'avait dit que c'était un pv
de brouille oui non c'est la petite joy
qui vise à une adq crise d'ado
paravent très compliquée elle est en
pleine croissance pubères quel âge est
là qu il ya quinze ans je croyais en
moi nous écrire nos enfants via les
réseaux wi délieront salle au nom soit
surtout dans un message un petit peu
comme ça en jolie vim j'te fais passer
un message d'amour mais en même temps je
fais passer des messages subliminaux qui
sont des tacles
avec sa mère
alors je vais vous dire quelque chose
mais c'est extrêmement perso ce que je
vous dit cette semaine il ya eu les soit
on aurait dû fêter les soixante douze
ans jean pierre pernaut et qui c'est
l'affection que j'ai pour lui et sa
femme aussi encore plus ses enfants j'ai
tourné pour un dock enfin je connais
bien tom formidable je sais très perso
j'ai eu un petit moment de gêne que sur
instagram ils ont mis un
gâteau d'anniversaire tu as eu 72 ans
les sous
moi j'ai un tout petit peu de mal avec
lui mais je suis un peu d'une génération
où on vit 16 ans ou instagram c'est beau
et on vient un peu ses emmerdes et c est
vivre tout ça est ce qu'on vit un peu
bizarre
ne vais pas quand on n'a pas vécu de
deuil etc on se moque un peu moi je me
moque pas attention on se moque pas mais
on se dit ah c'est hyper un public etc
mais je vous jure que quand on le vit
oui on a un besoin en train d'engager
partagé pour apaiser un peu sa
permanence a finalement c'était bien
famille tu n'as pas besoin de partager
une douleur importante avec 1 million de
personnes pardon mais que tu ne connais
pas petit loup pas grave on est un
milliard d'années on ne connaît pas les
maths il à la citrouille pernaut par
exemple assez fait déchirer sur les
réseaux sociaux ces derniers pour les
parce qu'elle a postée par exemple des
tic toc d'elle avec ses copines et c'est
comme si elle vivait une vie normale
après ce deuil sauf que c'est mais les
gens ne peuvent pas comprendre on a
besoin d'être entouré d'être un peu elle
a aussi procédé pas juste c'est
important de le souligner elle a aussi
posté des messages destinés à son papa
donc qui lui manque beaucoup et on a
posté plusieurs que ça ça rejoint ce que
tu disais c'est vrai que elle et son
frère tous les deux régulièrement
postent des messages même pour souhaiter
un bon anniversaire à leur maman ils le
font sur a gracié ne le font pas par un
sms comme nous en fassions mieux à la
salle buisson deuil comme il après moi
je vous avouerai et c'est dommage
d'aller sur la la la tombe de ma mère
oui je serais incapable de faire
instagram tu donc maintenant je
ne fais pas voyez c'était son
anniversaire il ya deux semaines je les
lis à deux semaines d'ailleurs pour son
anniversaire elle a rien elle n'a pas
communiqué sur son propre animation mais
jean pierre pernaut c'est pas quelqu'un
comme vous et moi c'est quelqu'un qui
est adoré par la france entière et ne
serait ce que l'on lui rendant hommage
pour la france et pour que les français
puisque se commémorer un petit peu ce
jour là voilà ce grand homme eh bien je
pense que il le faut plus pour les gens
pour les fans de jean pierre et je
rappelle que c'est un jeune en ce que je
dis c'est chacun des sur deux que je
peux certainement walker dans une
situation de toute façon insensée c'est
à dire que elle le fait ça a pas de
crise alors le
lan hiver cela exactement
alors qu'elle mourrait je me dis
toujours là là la méchanceté des réseaux
d'amis oui elle est assez horrible je
lis puis parfois quand je relis je me
mets quelques à quoi sa canne et je
réponds mais le n 10 ans les gens ce qui
se passe ça nous rassure de et quant à
laetitia elle a aussi été beaucoup
critiquée je sais pas si vous en aviez
parlé avec l'odeur m'avait été beaucoup
critiqués parce qu'on voit beaucoup ses
filles en boîte de nuit toute seule et
elle vivent son histoire d'amour avec
jalil les gens dit martin des gamines de
c'est 15 ans dans des boîtes de nuit où
circule la coke et tout ça est ce bien
raisonnable
donc elle sait aussi c'est encore moins
de 17 ans et non à causeur on a fait le
premier sujet sur jade allant en boîte
de nuit il ya quelques mois elle a
laissé sa mère était pas là c'est la
première fois qu'elle est toute seule à
paris avec ses copines elle sortait
régulièrement avec gardes du corps etc
mais elle s'est beaucoup amusé et on a
fait un parcours aller en boîte de nuit
à partir de 16 ans et humour en boîte
oui mais et puis pardon c'est moins
grotesque gala 62
tirs cadrés